Ce 14 février 1945, le président américain Roosevelt
passe un pacte avec le roi ibn Saoud, fondateur du royaume d'Arabie saoudite.
Les Américains vont protéger la dynastie saoudienne en échange d'un accès au pétrole.
Depuis 1945, Soviétiques et Américains
avaient décidé de s'imposer au Moyen-Orient pour garantir leurs approvisionnements en pétrole.
Les Américains soutenaient les monarchies du Golfe, l'Iran et Israël.
Les Soviétiques, eux, s'étaient alliés au panarabisme de l'Egyptien Nasser
et aux régimes laïques de Saddam Hussein en Irak ou d'Hafez el-Assad en Syrie.
Avec ce face-à-face, c'était un peu de la guerre froide qui s'était déplacée au coeur du Proche-Orient.
Et, comme en Europe, il y avait un équilibre des terreurs qui garantissait la paix.
Ce fragile équilibre allait s'effondrer après 1979, avec la renaissance d'un islamisme politique.
Téhéran, l'ayatollah Khomeini renverse le régime du shah d'Iran.
C'est la révolution iranienne.
Le 11 février 1979, les chancelleries occidentales
regardent, incrédules, la naissance d'une république islamique.
Quelques mois plus tard, le 20 novembre, à La Mecque,
des djihadistes prennent en otage des pèlerins autour de la Kaaba.
Ils reprochent aux Saoudiens de laisser l'islam s'occidentaliser
et plaident pour une interprétation plus rigoriste des textes.
Après cet événement, les Saoudiens soutiendront la branche wahhabite
et faciliteront l'extension d'un islamisme politique au Proche et Moyen-Orient.
On ignore alors que ce face-à-face entre islam et Occident
va être au coeur des relations internationales pour les 50 ans à venir.
Après cette année 1979, on assiste à une montée continue de l'islam politique.
En 1980, ce sont des djihadistes aidés par la CIA qui s'opposent à l'invasion soviétique en Afghanistan.
Ce sont des fondamentalistes qui assassineront Anouar el-Sadate en Egypte.
Sa mort sera fêtée dans les rues de Damas ou Tripoli.
Au milieu des années 80, le Liban sera déstabilisé par le Hezbollah libanais,
bras armé des Iraniens, qui multipliera enlèvements et attentats.
Plus près de nous, en 1990, le Front islamique du Salut remporte les élections en Algérie.
La déliquescence des Etats arabes, leur corruption ont alimenté des oppositions protéiformes.
Sur les décombres de l'Etat irakien, une force émerge. Il s'agit de l'Etat islamique.
- C'est un groupe qui a fait fortune, en réalité, bien avant sa prise d'assaut de Mossoul en 2014,
parce que dès l'année 2010, y a reformation du groupe sur le terrain irakien,
ce qui est complètement passé inaperçu à l'époque.
Et après le retrait américain à partir de 2012, l'Etat islamique, les djihadistes
ont fait leur retour déjà dans les villes irakiennes,
négociant un certain nombre d'accords avec les élites locales,
les dignitaires, les tribus, les religieux pour prendre le pouvoir.
- Cette stratégie victorieuse a été pensée pour un homme, Abou Bakr al-Baghdadi.
C'est lui qui dirige ce mouvement
qui se répand telle une pieuvres sur les provinces irakiennes et syriennes.
Il veut revenir à l'époque triomphante du monde arabe, celui qui défiait l'Occident chrétien.
Il est le calife et décide de restaurer le califat le 29 juin 2014.
Il se rêve en chef de tous les musulmans du monde.